there are few things in life that can
scare you the way a video game can
come on
god damn it sure movies are spooky but
holding that controller just adds an
extra layer of immersion that makes us
all the more prone to a good ol spooking
hey this is kurt
i'm going over eight of gaming's
scariest moments that have left most of
us
scarred for life of course this isn't a
comprehensive list of every scare so let
me know what horrifying moments scared
you stupid in the comments below hey and
while you're at it
consider subscribing to see more content
like this alright
you've been warned it's going to get
scary
if you've played dead space 2 you
already know exactly what i'm about to
mention
oh yes that scene leading up to the
game's conclusion poor old isaac clark
is faced with the game's most terrifying
foe and no not another necromorph but
instead
a needle that you have to carefully
guide in a limited amount of time
right into his pupil failure to do so
results
in uh well this
this is one of those rare occurrences in
games where regardless if you fail or
succeed
you're bound to wince and screech as
your body tenses into a rigo mortis-like
state
and it's absolutely brilliant i hate it
even when you think you've seen all that
dead space 2 has to throw at you from
countless terrifying jump scares to its
most disgusting enemies
nothing can prepare you for this scene
dead space took our expectations and
flung them into the deep void of space
while also turning a bad case of
trypanophobia
up to 11. the result is unfortunately
unforgettable in the best way possible
of course if the concept of being
stranded alone in deep space wasn't
enough
developer visceral games said hey what
other fears can we throw into the mix
needles eye gouging sure why not thanks
visceral games i hate you
i love you dead space is a franchise
defined by its violence
scares and how it subverts player
expectations and this scene
encapsulated all of that masterfully and
even 10 years since playing it it's
impossible
not to squirm at the thought of it
this infamous moment from resident evil
7 is arguably
one of the most finely orchestrated jump
scares in horror gaming history
what makes it so devilish is that capcom
crafted the opening area of the game to
be
incredibly oppressive with just a few
small disgusting and decrepit rooms to
explore in a grimy near a corridor that
doesn't leave much room to move
connecting them and to make matters
worse
jack baker the patriarch of the maniacal
family that is holding you captive
is pacing around in the same area with
you capcom being the sly dogs they are
makes you focus all of your attention on
trying to know where jack
is so you can avoid him you start to
believe you know jack's patterns and
style of movement
and even start to think you understand
his behavior even if he is a lunatic
and then as you're sulking through a
corridor and moving towards your escape
point
this happens
you wasted your time he bust through the
wall all kool-aid man's style like it
was made of tissue paper
the sudden sound of the wall erupting
ethan's gasp and the realization that
jack knew exactly
what you were up to and now stands in
your way not only made for an amazing
jump scare but also a fantastic
set piece that built tension and then
expertly leveraged it for a cinematic
moment
when reacting to video game moments were
on the come up as a hot new thing to
watch on youtube
one of the more popular games was
amnesia the dark descent a game where
your own character sanity
was pushed to its extremes the closer to
breaking point your character's mind got
the more twisted the world would become
it was a game about staying in the light
because horrifying things
awaited in the darkness one of the more
memorable scares in amnesia involved
walking through what felt like an
endlessly
snaking and looping corridor that was
sparsely lit
it felt like an inescapable maze and the
pounding music with its choir-like
vocals made it feel like
something was closing in on you and oh
something was ah
how what what did i just do
the moment you step foot into the water
the sound of some sort of monstrous
behemoth stomping towards you pierced
through
except surveying the environment
revealed nothing it's only when you look
at the water that you realize that the
creature can't be seen
only the splashing of water indicated
where it was
and the moment your feet touched water
it would charge towards you to escape
you needed to jump between objects in
the environment which
the first time through felt like an
impossible task the consistent
sense of tension and dread this moment
created had most people sitting in front
of their screens with all their muscles
clenched
willing themselves to move and for those
watching on youtube it offered a lovely
sense of stride and freuda to see people
losing their minds as they try to figure
out what's going on
of course kojima and guillermo del
toro's short-lived masterpiece
had to go on here but the question
remains which part of pt
is the spookiest was it turning the
corner and seeing lisa for the first
time
was it that cruding talking fetus in the
sink or even the knowledge that came
years after the game was released and
then pulled
that lisa was scripted to follow you
around the game the whole
damn time and you had no idea while all
terrifying in their own right
this encounter with lisa is the scariest
of them all
once you get over the jump scare of the
pain of glass shattering in front of you
seemingly out of nowhere there's a
further fright that is actually
very easily missed lisa leering down at
you from the balcony above
before skulking back into the darkness
it's a real one-two punch of scares and
makes me even sadder that kojima and del
toro's project was
cancelled outlasts greatest achievement
is the increasingly twisted characters
you encounter through your harrowing
trip
and mount massive asylum from the
visually grotesque to the more subtly
disturbing but by far the most
memorable of them all is eddie gluskin
from the whistleblower expansion
eddie is a simple man with a simple
dream he just wants a happy family and
the fact that he's locked up in an
asylum full of serial killers
isn't gonna stop him referred to as the
groom
by other patients what eddie does to his
brides to be
is beyond disturbing and to be perfectly
frank this channel would lose
all of its ad revenue if we showed it to
you what makes eddie so horrifying is
how charming he presents himself
but make no mistake he is domestic abuse
and misogyny taken to absolute
extremes and it all culminates in one of
the most
uncomfortable scenes ever put in a game
just when you think you're safe hidden
in a locker eddie seals the door
shut and drags you to his workshop
eventually it's your turn and the player
is strapped naked to a table with a
buzzsaw aimed
right at your genitals good lord this is
the moment where you as a player need to
decide if you're gonna stick with it or
go
nope i'm out and turn the game off
unlike a jump scare
the horror is clear and present and you
can't look away
at least in the game i'm sure you know
the classic tried and true scare in
horror movies where the character is
looking in the medicine cabinet mirror
opens it and then closes it to reveal
that something is standing behind them
well silent health 3 takes that trite
scare
and instead makes you the player the
focal point
of terror there's a storeroom with a
giant mirror but you may not want to
stick around to check yourself out as
things will start to get a little creepy
as you watch heather's reflection is
overcome as the blood consumes the room
spreading across it and eventually
enveloping her completely
all while you just stand there but wait
around for too long
and
[Music]
among all of silent hill 3's most
terrifying moments
this one fed directly into heather
mason's fears of mirrors
making it all the more impactful it's
eerie enough to make you think twice
about looking at yourself in the mirror
for too long next time you're alone
every gamer knows the feeling of
constantly saving your game pressing
pauses tabbing through prompts
save overwrite back to playing the game
it's practically muscle memory for a lot
of us
well eternal darkness took that gaming
ritual and turned it into one of the
most panic inducing moments
ever experienced in a horror game when
you're going to save your game you'll be
prompted with
a are you sure you want to delete all of
your saved games
regardless of what you choose even if
it's continue without saving
the game initiates this
it forces you to sit in agonizing
torment as you try to come to grips with
whether you accidentally press the wrong
thing
or if it's a bug or if the game is just
messing with you again
eternal darkness is a game all about
toying with your sanity and i mean that
quite literally not only is the game
scary on its own
it ups the ante by playing into your
most inner gaming paranoia and fears
like shutting off the tv or switching
video inputs when you least expect it
or suddenly turning the volume down most
effects
however wouldn't really hold up these
days unless you're still gaming on a crt
tv
and in that case you're weird and you're
cool
but of all the ways eternal darkness
messes with you losing your save data is
still one that prevails today
even with cloud saves it's still enough
of a scare to send a jolt of worry
through your bloodstream
the scare seemed so cruel that even mr
nintendo himself
miyamoto was concerned that it might
cause players to break their gamecubes
out of frustration alright
this is the last one because it's a
major spoiler for doki doki literature
club which
on the surface is a pleasant visual
novel about getting to know the girls in
your after school club
however the game takes a huge shift and
underlying the pleasant conversations
about poetry
is something altogether much more
sinister over the course of the game the
girls in the club lose their grip on
sanity and can die
in extremely upsetting ways but the one
that sticks out the most
is natsuki who starts by having
relatively normal conversation about
writing but
after presenting you with a nonsensical
poem she quickly becomes
more and more unhinged until
there are more messed up things to
uncover in doki doki literature club
which is free on steam
right now and you should definitely try
it
if you're looking forward to pooping
your pants at more video games keep an
eye out on our resident evil village
coverage
capcom's next installment is looking
terrifying and we'll always have the
latest so
subscribe for more so that was eight of
gaming's scariest moments
if you have your own moments that you
still lie awake at night thinking about
drop them in the comments below and we
might do a follow-up video with your
suggestions
alright thanks for watching till next
time see you later
[Music]
so
[Music]
you